I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark hi hi didn't misspell anything
what
welcome back to my x-men series of
reviews if you've been following my
channel I've been talking about the
x-men films I haven't yet reviewed and
today I brought on my good friend of
Flik Vic to talk about the best one but
not only are you going to help me with
this review you're going to do an
unboxing for it that's right Chris I am
by the way fazer guys how are you
but without further ado let's
rambunctious the lush edition of
Wolverine with an X Wow now I'm gonna
open this up because we're nerd that we
like dirty stuff and we're talking about
X min so x-men stuff now what I like to
do Christmas Hanukkah put his arms up
and this is the shrenger where he
flexing the biceps and it shows anger
and rage if you pay close attention
right here the detail the X American
Claus in the boldest tip that's what we
don't hold your eyes out mole this
- x-men origins this was an attempt at a
big franchise I think it failed on every
level possible directing style
Fiji's acting script yes I mean when a
studio makes a film and that film has
specific points that reference and make
fun of this one Deadpool yeah
when another student lay I'll just make
a movie and make fun of the last thing
we tried to do like that's just it
baffles me that this film and the
Wolverine have the same IMDB score it
says something about our culture and the
blind love for bad things and it
terrifies me and the saddest thing is
this movie it was supposed to be the
starting point to an entire universe of
soul x-men spin-off movies it looks like
the Marvel Universe is doing right
except better so this movie always with
an open credit sequence we got Wolverine
and Sabretooth and they're kicking ass
in various wars and I just thought this
was a big missed opportunity to me it
felt like that was a movie I'd rather
see like what was good old we'll be
doing in various world wars like that
would have been a lot more fun than just
like here's me as weapon a crime
adamantium I'm mad at you can you
imagine warring and Civil War Vietnam
World War 1 World War 2
could you imagine all these amazing
things I can't because the movie gave us
four minutes of a montage opening
sequence just glossing over all this
amazing stuff to work with and they said
you know what all this good stuff throw
it over there let's just jump into some
mediocre storyline with the blob yeah
really and will.i.am
from from black side tennis like what is
he doing it smooth let's just have
Justin Bieber being the next one why not
let's just do it I think the weather
outside is just like joined our
depression it's a sore x-men origins
aside if there's lightning in a tree
fall through the ceiling here it was
meant to be in Sabre suits just comes in
and just got giggles Eve under chin but
he comes in on wires
he just glides in yeah cuz the wire work
in this movie it is incredible there's a
sequence in the beginning where agent
zero is just like flipping over a fence
I get that he's a mutants and everything
but it just looks so bad he's like
climbing up the side of a building it's
one notch away from him just dangling on
why
like this and you see a crane above his
head yes it's so terrible there's the
laws of physics and gravity just don't
apply to this movie now from the opening
scene this movie takes place in 1800 you
have young Logan young Sabretooth and
then when Logan finally hits mutant
puberty and his little shriveling bone
claws come out and that's where you know
that you might not be watching the best
movie that was the first sign I remember
seeing this in theaters and being like
this suck my friends like know what's
good you know your head will the reason
it I was like um that was really bad
guys like what are you watching what
movie did you see were you aware when
you first watch this movie that the CG
was bad yes I mean yes yes I liked the
x-men animated cartoon from the 90s when
I was a kid quite a bit but I was a
fucking cartoon yeah and this is a
live-action movie I don't need to look
like a cartoon when he's in front of the
mirror and he's like t'get and it looks
like somebody just went in there with
like you know Microsoft Paint and it's
just animated who claws one frame at a
time and I remember the first time I
watched it as well this movie was leaked
like five months early or something like
that when I was watching that leaked
version it was pre she G like some of
the elements were there some work I was
like oh yeah his claws are look way
better this movie hits theatres I
watched the movie in the movie theater
and they look the same and I was like
what do they do what did you do what
have you done but the thing about
Wolverines cause this movie like the
scene you just said in the bathroom at
the old people's house before they get
violently murdered it's great scene the
frame right and a lighting doesn't even
memo not at all like they start
flickering yet the other thing I hated
about the fact that he becomes Weapon X
and he's like dealing with this
adamantium and everything if you
remember his flashback in like x-men 2
when he when he has a flashback that
sequence
he's like holding his claws out he's
like oh my god there's blood all over me
fucking pissed
in the first x-men rogue ask Wolverine
when they come up
does it hurt
thank you time so maybe during this
sequence where he's first discovering
that adamantium metal has been graphed
throughout his entire skeleton you know
he might be experiencing a little pain
agony he's on form of depression or
anger but no it's like a comical scene
in a bathroom where he breaks the old
people's radiator and their sink and he
brings out he like I sworn on paper like
it's supposed to be funny it's like no
this guy should be an intense pain right
now why is this a joke except it's like
a comedy movie were a boy going through
puberty and he just discovers the first
hair at his ball sack yeah mom tries to
come in the bathroom it's the thing is
this movie has no humanity and has no
real motion everything's so superficial
in this movie there's a sequence that I
think we both thought was really funny
where Wolverine wakes up from a dream
it's like did he just come looks like
we're gonna need me she kiddin me
did you like when Agent Zero pulls out
his gun and shoots Wolverines cigar out
of his mouth that was a quintessential
scene for this movie it really developed
those characters and the lackluster CG
really sold me on the story yeah yeah
did you like the the moon story she
tells to them about the the coo coo
cachoo the cuckoo becomes alluring and
we're just trying to set up the title
for this movie and give you a name even
though my whole subplot will later be
revealed that I'm lying to you but we're
gonna show you on this shitty talk about
it could you
exactly and that really when you go back
and watch the movie edge ii was real to
me too i was really in love with you
that story i told you and everything i
meant it from the bottom of my heart
like oh my god just just shoot me give
me an adamantium bullets in my fucking
head so i can forget about this movie
if this really could use just one thing
right it could have okay action scenes
or at least convincing action scenes or
well shot or choreograph these no we
have a lot of high frame rate shaky cam
multiple angle bullshit I mean there's
even a sequence where like a bunch of
logs fall on top of Wolverine and they
just kind of go this they fall flat with
no vibrations no jitters nothing they
just go gravity stops instantly it's
exactly when Deadpool first shows up and
the end like he goes into a room and
he's just swinging his swords around
like blocking all the bullets perfectly
it just it just looks like Ryan Reynolds
just walked around going like this
please add convincing CG to make this
look cool this is all I can do when you
compare that blocking tactic to the one
that Wolverine uses at the end of the
movie to block side pull shitty
cyclopses beam vision where he's just
holding him right here like this
hey depa wanna just look up and kill him
stop aiming for the claws when that
happened in the movie we just read watch
it I went is this this is real this
happened
Deadpool's eyes turned black an issue to
bean I have his eyes and Wolverine like
blocks it like it's Dragon Ball Z or
something like what what is this what's
happening it's like this horrible 360 CG
battle on top of a smokestack yeah oh my
god and they so is mouth shut
of course they show they so shut
Deadpool's mouth the Merc with the mouth
his mouth is so shut John in this movie
they say so Deadpool mouth shut
why don't you just fucking take away
Hulk's strength you know why don't you
just right you just take away Wolverines
claws why you just make Superman just be
like a poor depressed college student
who can't fly why don't you give Thor
screwdriver instead of a hammer now
anarchy Chris why don't you just like
make Batman just be like a Dracula
cosplayer and that's it sounds like a
movie that might develop next year yeah
copyright Chris Buckman it's nothing
Ryan Reynolds playing Deadpool by the
end of the movie it's Scott Adkins this
is yes another actor it's not even Ryan
Reynolds it looks like a close-up of him
it's not not even once
it's got at least yeah wow I didn't know
that yeah isn't that phenomenal you know
of course is the big Weapon X scene
where he comes out of the water and
trains and everything and unfortunately
they had to like cut it together and
it's weird like 300 style of directing
like slow fast mo like can you just show
it really cool like why'd you have to
have it be like
oh wow like it was like this weird fast
slow-mo bullshit I hate it I'm not
giving away I kind of enjoyed it it
looked like you Jag we got a pump right
before the seat oh you know he did but
during that really intense scene they
really bogged down because every other
character in the room is like I don't I
think he's gonna survive it I don't know
if he's gonna survive it oh you never
survive it heart rate at 180 heart rate
at 120 I think he's going to survive it
maybe I don't fuck it we know what
happens this is a prequel we know
they're eventually Wolverine will lose
his memory and that he gets turned into
Weapon X it's like they just took
everything that we know happens and try
to make it happen in the most boring
unconvincing way and then add little
bullshit things in there like gambit
showing up or a fight scene with the
blob in a boxing ring that we don't need
to see or like I said will I am from
black-eyed peas it's like we know
exactly what's going to happen this is
just one of those things like hey you
know that story you know here's how it
happened
speaking of cringy cheesy shit just put
in there when he escapes after being
Weapon X from the facility that they
transform and Matt the seal he cuts
through the door in one big X and the
other reason they made that is so they
could shoehorn it into the trailer it
was for marketing reasons only and that
was it and by the way from a technical
standpoint if you're going to break
through a steel door to cut it open you
wouldn't make it act and then punch the
bottom out you make a circle or a square
I get why they didn't do that but it's
just like open the door or don't do it
at all can you imagine if you made it oh
and just came out with like I'm oh man
so Wolverine second big action scene as
adamantium Wolverine is this helicopter
sequence where we have this amazing shot
yes it's incredible with Wolverine on a
motorcycle and he uses his claws in the
dirt to turn the motorcycle around and
then he's like on top of a truck and the
reaction in his face one that when the
rocket blows on the truck he knows he's
about to get catapulted through the air
like a fucking slingshot he goes like oh
and then like this gets shot up in the
air a billion feet somehow avoids the
helicopter rudder this is the sequence
in the theater I was like is this
unfinished do they forget to do this in
editing is this pre visual well I love
that sequence because it goes from zero
to a billion instantaneously old people
just got shot to death the next thing is
he forgets how to use brakes on a
motorcycle so you uses the quad and then
he turns into Superman and take down a
helicopter it does it's baffling to me
that anyone likes this because there are
people who like this movie there are
people who like this movie look if you
like this movie and it's just because
you enjoy it you know like it's okay and
you like to watch it and but you
understand that this is like one of the
worst superhero movies of all time then
that's fine kind of like how sometimes I
watch Batman and Robin to make fun of it
but I know it's shit because if you
genuinely like x-men origins I don't get
it I'm sorry this movie's horrible in
all fairness to this movie I'm going to
be positive for about the next fourteen
second okay there are some good ideas in
this movie there was good ideas
especially with the opening montage
sequences and there's a few ideas where
he actually does have a little bit of
motion and you can see that Wolverine
inside of them but they're terribly
executed ideas absolutely I mean the
best part of the movie is Hugh Jackman I
mean like he's great as Wolverine you
know you Byron's the character he gives
emotion to the character even when the
script is asking him to say horrendous
lines of dialogue and do hilariously
silly things in front of a green screen
he's great as this character he's the
PISA saving grace of this movie and
that's really it and of course at the
end of the helicopter sequence he he
ignites like fuel on fire and walks away
like it's
bad boy 3 starring Hugh Jackman just
cringy stereotypical action movie
slow-mo the wind's blowing a but he
doesn't blink not world not now now just
for two seconds can we talk like a
fucking blob in this movie why not
he looks like chewed-up bubble gum and
that entire scene where takes place in
the boxing match with him and Logan
going back and forth it felt like a
slapstick comedy movie the way it was
put together hey bub
but burner call me blob hey I mean Fred
that was so dumb it's like hey let's
have Wolverine say his big bub line did
you recover a blob like that's the
that's the screenwriting just terrible I
like that's the dialogue this movie
didn't know what it wanted to be no it's
either bad boys or it's like a serious
movie like a romance where it's tragic
it's like a brothers brothers are
fighting and they hate each other story
it's a CGI mess it's a hilarious
slapstick comedy with the blob doll
Wolverine was a good movie until the end
because it betrayed its tone it became
really silly yeah but the serious stuff
up until then I really liked origins is
just like that throughout the entire
film like a big rocky just mess this
movie was written in such a way that it
couldn't help itself but be bloated they
try to shoo him in every mutant that
they could gand it Cyclops
they almost try to make it like an
origin story to Deadpool but why we
would ever start Deadpool off like that
I'm not quite sure they almost committed
suicide for every character in one movie
but this one we waste so much time with
just dumb subplots and scenes and little
tidbits of terrible tge like the cigar
scene but the one that was such a
substantial waste of time was when it's
finally revealed at the end of the movie
that his wife of six years turns out to
be a spy for Stryker that didn't need to
happen like he she could have been a
legitimate woman that he loved she dies
and he goes on a revenge it's true
because she says like it was real for me
too okay so you're right back where he
started
so why were you a spy why'd you have to
die and they lose his memory never sees
her again so what does that add to this
film besides one scene where he goes
like done
you're alive his emotion last like 12
seconds he goes up and he just walks
away he does it okay cool right and then
yesterday like free all the mutants and
everything with his claws but of course
the only mutants this guy is captured
which by the way he's capturing mutants
to like give their powers and energy to
Deadpool we just process that for a
second and Wolverine is freeing all the
mutants that are in cages so it's like I
guess you only like you know took like
the semi kind of maybe powerful mutants
they can't break out of cages yeah
they're so powerful they can't break out
of a chicken water that you put them in
there's a little girl in the first x-men
that can walk through walls
yeah what the hell is going on what's
going on with this movie no knows but
Cyclops is also in one of those cages I
believe why doesn't he just take his
glasses off and saves the day because
John and then really would be over I'm
sorry yeah but at least we got that
really cool scene where Wolverine opens
the cages up yeah Jing Jing Jing kidding
me you like how they just ran through
all the cages and like didn't even look
to make sure he wasn't going to slice a
child's finger off like ever you can
dive in the open occasion yes that'd be
so great he's like Oh running on he's
like I'm a badass any wool turns around
they're all dead
so in the big epic bloated finale where
Deadpool is teleporting around by the
way cuz Deadpool can teleport yeah
Sabretooth just shows up and says nobody
kills him but me nobody kills you but me
nobody kills Jack Roth while I'm around
that's the address of that lecture for
me like we said you know fucking
Deadpool shoots beams and shit now and
Wolverine can block it with his claws
and of course
Wolvie loses his memory because striker
shoots some of the bullet and I mean
why's this movie happening money
yeah you're sweet
holy ye what is that what the fuck is
that
well guys thank you so much for watching
my series of x-men reviews it's been a
great time talking x-men with you guys
thank you for joining me for clearly the
best most perfect classic x-men film
that has an applause this is my buddy
dyslexic you can definitely check out
his channel it's awesome you should
subscribe to it well thanks for having
me Chris I appreciate it I just wish we
could talk about better movies when we
collab it's true whenever we cut
wherever we get together it's like let's
talk about some shit shit shit movies
anyway guys thank you so much as always
for watching and as always did you like
this you can click right here and get
Minhaj that was a reenactment of the
special effects in excellent and the
acting and the way the camera was yeah
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]